on va demander des étudiants vous êtes
étudiant quoi avec les mamans on parle
beaucoup d'économies en ce moment
campagne électorale tout ce que vous en
pensez
audika l'équipe qui on est performant
travail
je pense qu'avant de live sur des
questions à ce qu'ils aient date
pourquoi qu'on ne peut assurément
d'entrepreneurs au québec
ils ont vraiment mais on arrivait qu'on
apprenne services pour la musculation la
santé qui peut financer mon nom c'est
difficile pourquoi faudrait-il difficile
éventuellement si ça va en outre devoir
qui combat entre son mari travaille tête
certainement new orleans politique ou un
pacte va devoir trouver des solutions
d'abord la démographie faire en sorte
qu' on est moins à leur première chance
parce qu'il n'est pas parti libéral ces
deux partis un peu de baby boomers les
seuils viendra nous chercher des partis
se rétablir d'une main personnellement
les griffes arctique son petit novateur
à cake c'est comme ça va souvent lieu en
particulier à l'acheter québec c'est
assez médiocre garde tout autour de nous
on aime et on va prendre à gauche pour
économiser qu'on veut partir des choses
qui on voit bien que les savoirs
extrêmement tous ces deux fois rentrés
en possession de deux terrains
immobiliers ce qui est chose qui
troublante
j'arrive à tes portes ni souverainiste
français -qui membres m'ont bonne si
vous allez voir fait aucune idée
s'intéresse à jenny bicks vous allez
voter pour tout le monde